voici donc la première d' armes égales
c'est un face à face mais ce n'est pas
un face à face comme les autres monsieur
michel debré monsieur jacques duclos qui
sont ici ce soir ne vont pas se
contenter de présenter oralement leurs
arguments ils l'ont également vous
présenter leurs idées en images pour
cela depuis un mois environ
ils ont travaillé chacun à la
réalisation d'un film
leur film le problème pour eux étaient
difficiles car ce ne sont pas des
cinéastes et il s'agissait d'adapter
leur langage qui est un langage d'hommes
politiques au cinéma vous allez donc
voir dans un instant leur film
auparavant un mot de l'émission elle se
déroulera si vous voulez en trois rounds
d'abord les films puis ans puis ensuite
un débat de type classique et enfin les
30 personnes qui sont ici autour des
tables que vous voyez poseront à l'un et
à l'autre des deux protagonistes une
série de questions vous êtes donc voir
dans un instant les films mais
auparavant si vous voulez bien les
présentations qui est monsieur debré qui
est monsieur du club michel debré eu 58
ans le mois dernier il est le fils du
professeur robert debré membre de
l'institut promoteurs en 1962 la réforme
des études médicales michel debré est
docteur en droit et diplômé de sciences
politiques
auditeur puis maître des requêtes au
conseil d'état il épouse en 1936
anne-marie lemaresquier de cette union
naîtront quatre garçons vincent françois
et les jumeaux bernard jean louis
mobilisé en 1939 comme officier de
cavalerie prisonniers en 40 il s'évade
puis il participe à la résistance ainsi
en 1943 il est à la fois membre du
comité directeur de ceux de la
résistance et adjoint au délégué en
france du gouvernement de londres est
d'alger commissaire de la république à
angers 44 45
il est ensuite chargé de mission pour la
réforme administrative auprès du général
de gaulle président du gouvernement
provisoire sénateurs d'indre-et-loire 48
58 il devient garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice le 1er juin 58 premier
ministre le 8 janvier 59 1963 élu député
umr unités de la réunion 1966 ministre
de l'économie et des finances et maire
conseiller général d'amboise mai 68
ministre des affaires étrangères 1969
ministre d'état chargé de la défense
nationale
auteur de neuf ouvrages politiques paru
en librairie réalise ces quinze derniers
jours son premier film jacques duclos 73
ans le doyen des dirigeants du pcf n'est
alloué dans les hautes-pyrénées ouvrier
pâtissier mobilisés et blessé à verdun
est fait prisonnier au chemin des dames
a épousé en 1937 une infirmière
mademoiselle gilbert troupe adhère au
parti communiste le jour de la fondation
de celui ci le 30 décembre 1920 élu au
comité central depuis 1926 fait de très
nombreux voyages en rss en allemagne en
espagne un en chine en 1956 est
plusieurs à hanoi
c'est en deçà vit dans la clandestinité
3 de 1927 à 1930 et 4 pendant
l'occupation grande activité
parlementaire député de 28 à 32 de 36 à
40 de 46 à 58 puis sénateur autant que
pour le parti c'est pour lui que 21 52%
des électeurs se prononcent lorsqu en
1969 il est désigné pour affronter le
suffrage universel pour la présidence de
la république
1970 réélu au bureau politique du comité
central
les présentations sont faites maintenant
comme dans un match de football
je vais tirer au sort de l'ordre de
passage des films monsieur michel debré
puisque vous venez le premier dans
l'ordre alphabétique que choisissez-vous
pile ou face
bien vous avez gagné choisissez-vous de
passer que votre fils passe le premier
où passe la seconde
le second bien monsieur du clan c'est
donc votre film qui va passer en premier
alors vous allez donc voir maintenant le
film réalisée sous la responsabilité de
monsieur jacques duclos
je précise que le commentaire que vous
allez entendre est de monsieur jacques
duclos lui même nous sommes bien
d'accord monsieur du club 1792 le roi
louis saez étaient étonnés d'entendre
crier vive la nation
c'était l'expression nouvelle de l'idée
de patrie les aristocrates pour qui la
patrie disparaissait avec les privilèges
s'était réfugié à problèmes
moi c'est bien fait j'adore les
prussiens et depuis le jour béni où j'ai
appris qu'ils n'achètent avec nous je
cherche toutes les occasions et
d'acclamer 1870 lampe ils écroulent et
jules fable ministres affaires
étrangères rencontrait secrètement
bismarck au château des rois de fil à
ferrières le gouvernement de la défense
nationale devenait selon le mode carmack
celui de la défection menace de coeur le
peuple de paris voulait se barde
mais les gouvernants préféré la défaite
à la victoire remportée par le peuple le
18 mars 1871 la commune de paris étaient
victorieuses bismarck convoya ap tiers
les prisonniers de guerre français pour
la broyé dans le sang la guerre de
1914-1918 qui coûta la vie à un million
trois cent quinze mille français
rapporte à d'énormes profits aux
fournisseurs de guerre aussi anatole
france pour étudier
en quoi mourir pour la patrie on meurt
pour des industriels essaient mêmes
profiteurs de guerre potentats de la
haute banque de la grande industrie mais
content de la victoire du front
populaire en 1936 n'hésitez pas à
proclamer plutôt hitler que le front
populaire 1940 pétain et hitler à
montoire c'est la france traille
conséquence de l'abandon de l'espagne
républicaine et de la capitulation des
munich c'est l'occupation hitlérienne la
classe ouvrière seul dans sa masse
fidèles à la france propane et lutte
contre l'envahisseur mai 1941 les
mineurs du nord et du pas de calais
vivent dans ces corps on se met en grève
il associe l'exigence la libération de
la patrie à leurs revendications
immédiates
pendant ce temps les grands capitalistes
français faisait des affaires avec leurs
congénères hitlérien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la police des traces de vichy
travaillant pour le compte de la des
chapeaux pour chasser les patriotes sont
accusés d'être des communistes
cependant la répression ne les empêcha
pas de s'unir de s'armer et de se barrer
[Applaudissements]
tel était le mot d'or du parti
communiste français
[Applaudissements]
notre parti qui aux heures sombres de
l'occupation hitlériennes l'ugtt a
héroïquement pour la délivrance la
patrie et qui aujourd'hui lutte pour la
défense des intérêts de la classe
ouvrière et du peuple en même temps que
pour la sauvegarde de l'indépendance de
la france est conscient de sa force et
de l'ampleur des tâches qui lui
incombent en pleine clarté nous faisons
le procès de la politique des monopoles
capitalistes qui font peser sur la place
molière et sur le peuple france le poids
de leur exploitation de leur oppression
qui pillent les richesses du pays
brad le patrimoine national et met
l'indépendance de la france en péril moi
je pense qu'on parle de nation j'aurais
tendance à dire inciter une chanson un
peu la france des travailleurs
c'est à dire c'est une chanson de jean
ferrat c'est bien tout le patrimoine
culturel
nos usines enfin absolument tout tout ce
que les travailleurs ont créé de leurs
mains que ce soit avec leurs mains ou
avec leur tête
enfin pour moi en tant qu'ouvrier c'est
surtout mon usine un moment où 45 46 on
a nationalisé l'industrie aéronautique
c'est à dire qu'en fait on a donné les
moyens à la nation de réaliser un
programme de réaliser et de donner donc
par là même les moyens aux ouvriers
d'avoir un emploi premièrement et
surtout d'exercer une qualification
importante qui a la caractéristique de
l'industrie en ce moment on est en train
en fait de faire l'opération contraire
qui est de dénationaliser et qui est au
profit données nationalisée au profit de
capitaux privés et pour les ouvriers ça
amènera en fait des conséquences
importantes puisque si les américains
prennent le contrôle de notre société on
ne viendra en fait des sous traitants et
on n'aura plus besoin d'ouvriers
professionnels comme on en a besoin en
ce moment
des os ont à faire et on aura donc une
perte importante pour les ouvriers de
notre qualification et pour la nation du
capital qu'elle a investi justement dans
ces ouvriers dans ces travailleurs le
patriotisme des travailleurs m l'upa
l'internationalisme
il n'oublie pas le célèbre mode horde
prolétaires de tous les pays unissez
vous
l'intérêt des ingénieurs un site avec
l'intérêt national par ce qui coïncide
avec le développement de l'économie
nationale
est ce que c'est une couche qui est très
important pour ce développement est que
justement les problèmes que rencontrent
aujourd'hui les ingénieurs se sont ceux
qui résultent du freinage de
développement par le régime actuel
par exemple on dit on y vient souvent et
on dit en particulier les df1 chercheurs
et terme et finit à 35 ans et si
précisément l'objectif de leur travail
c'était de satisfaire les besoins de la
communauté nationale
on ne pourrait pas dire cela on aurait
besoin de se servir d'eux au delà de 35
ans et on prendrait les mesures pour que
cela soit possible c'est à dire que l'on
va les mesures pour leur formation
permanente façon à ce qu'ils puissent
suivre le développement des sciences et
les techniques et dans la mesure où
l'objectif ce n'est pas cela la mesure
où c'est justement de servir des
intérêts privés
l'intérêt des décomptes société
capitaliste on n'en a pas besoin de cela
au moment où la compagnie bulles en 1165
a été vendu votre site américain de
general electric
des gens allaient travailler avait
acquis un savoir faire chez lui l'avait
fabriqué un ordinateur très en avance
pour l'époque et malgré des difficultés
financières bien que les délais des
patchs ont été tenues que la compagnie
bulles a dû discuter financière on
pouvait utiliser tout cet acquis du coup
qu'il suffisait de trouver le
financement conforme à l'intérêt
national de la nationaliser la compagnie
bulles les travailleurs c'est à boucles
demandez vous avez conscience que c'est
la seule solution
tous ensemble ces gens la vie de ceux
qui se formeront aussi maintenant on
pourrait faire les équipes
beaucoup plus solide encore on pourrait
surtout face à des nouvelles demandes
face à toutes les perspectives de
l'informatique actuellement on pourrait
réaliser des choses originales à la fois
il voyait en progrès des choses qui
freinent que le pays se serait plus beau
que dans la mesure où encore une fois
vous nous appartiendrait aux gens qui
travaillent de 1954 1968 la population
active agricole a diminué de plus de
deux millions de personnes
vous vous êtes né ici oui je suis né ici
père mon père est né dans une commune
limitrophe tout proche prochain le grand
père et son père également la terre
d'ici laquelle vous appartient non nous
sommes étaient appartient aux
propriétaires fonciers qui possède trois
domaines c'est quand même la clarinette
séparant la terre natale les terres dont
les petits et moyens paysans sont
chassés deviennent la propriété de
grands capitalistes française et de
longer véritable fléau des temps
modernes
le gouvernement pense moins à aider ceux
qui travaillent à protéger les
spéculateurs qui ont joué la carte de
deutsche mark contre le franc est
exporté plus de 30 milliards
il s'est opposé à la levée du secret
bancaire que les terminaux
ces spéculateurs et l'organisent lui
même
la hausse des prix qui tourmentent temps
les ménagères de notre pays
la patrie c'est ce qui pour moi ce qui
me c'est un lien c'est un lien entre
entre entre français tu vois et c'est
peut-être grossier comme comme
explication 1
enfin on aime avoir quelque chose à soi
on aime qu'on soit français qu'on soit
il ya d'abord ceux de n'importe quelle
nationalité
on aime avoir quelque chose à soi toi on
a on a quand même hein comment un
attachement à la patrie pour moi c'est
la france pour doute c'est autre chose
on a on n'a rien attachement quand même
moule et on serait comme en chaire et
moi à ces secteurs ce machin là parce
que en effet il n'y a pas de le
prolétaires de tous les pays où on est
on est tous pareil hein mon à cette
chose qui qui qui me semble un nous
restera toujours
on essaye de le conserver notre bien
dans toute grève comme vous tuer dans
les grèves du mois de mai on essayé de
conserver l'autre y travaillent malgré
que cet outil de travail il a profité au
bâton on a essayé de conserver quand
même notre gagne pain
l'outil de travail 1
naturellement pour l'époque actuelle il
est au bénéfice du capitaliste mais dans
une époque qui à venir le plus proche
possible pour moi mais ce sera un outil
de travail pour l'ensemble des
travailleurs
ça sera un ultra y pour nous c'est à
dire qu'hier milliards un 'non' notre
bien-être
ça veut dire qu'à ce moment là ça fera
partie de la batterie
et alors dans dans cette usine les
grands honneurs
le travail s'est passé des choses
oui tout y travaillent il est quelle
nationalité il amène petit trail 20 de
l'américain 1 puisqu'il a été acheté par
le ce groupe tué l'impression qu'on
vendait quelque chose de toi oui puisque
on vendait lusine on vendait donc les
travailleurs de l'usiné en même temps
pour moi on m'a vendu et toi tu te sens
de quelle nationalité
je me sens toujours france est exploité
par un groupe de capitalistes qui qui
n'a aucune nationalité lui pour toi le
fait que tout l'outil de travail
n'appartiennent pas à quelqu'un du pays
de tout propre pays
c'est important dans notre dans notre
fierté oui dans ce quartier nous qu'est
ce que tu appelles fierté c'est à dire
que quand on sait qu'on travaille pour
une entreprise étrangère où les capitaux
le toit on en a parlé justement les
capitaux s'en vont à l'étranger ils
peuvent enfants ont donné les directions
fermé cuisine diminuer la production et
ainsi de suite tout comprendre alors les
capitaux restants en france malgré que
ça se paye un peu utopique mais quand
même on a cette tendance à dire on va
c'est une usine française
c'est un bien qui peut devenir nationale
parce que veut on pour un nationaliser
la compagnie des compteurs qui deviendra
alors à ce moment là un bien national à
bien à nous tous
[Musique]
on voit l'avenir de la france c'est la
france socialiste
oh
la première des deux chansons françaises
que nous avons évoquées exalte la patrie
la deuxième est selon l'expression du
poète la marseillaise pour toute
l'humanité
ces deux chansons nées de deux
révolutions ont fait le tour du monde
elles sont un des éléments du prestige
et de la grandeur de la france
[Musique]
voilà vous avez vu le film de monsieur
jacques duclos à présent le fils de
monsieur michel debré je rappelle qu'il
a été réalisé sous l'entière
responsabilité de monsieur michel debré
et que le commentaire est également dit
par monsieur michel debré vous êtes bien
d'accord là encore et pourquoi pas le
bonheur je l'appelais byers était
chevalier françois premier temps peur et
sans reproche et pour ça qu'il avait
ravi d'accueillir alto
donc vous êtes attachés tout ce qui est
français réservez pour conclure que vous
êtes patriotes au oui on aime bien son
pays on est fiers quand quelque chose de
bien que je pense et on est fiers on
regarde à la télé les sports et vie du
site en donnant les français gagne on
est content
notre équipe de rugby triomphe dans un
match aux sportifs nageurs skieurs
athlètes garçons ou filles font hisser
nos couleurs au mas de la victoire comme
eux nous ne sentons français dira-t-on
qu'il s'agit de compétition sportive où
l'esprit d'équipé s'étend aux
spectateurs et qu'il ne faut pas en
tirer de conclusions
mais regardez les grandes et belles
réalisations
quand elles sont l'oeuvre de français
quelle fierté naturelle
tournons nous vers l'histoire perçage et
oryx ce tête il y a deux mille ans on
pourrait croire qu'il s'agit d'un héros
de folklore cependant voyez le succès
populaire d'astérix jeanne d'arc 500 ans
après fait encore vibrer notre fierté et
notre reconnaissance
le panthéon tout solennelle qu'il est
est toujours visiter
et ce fut une grande cérémonie populaire
que le jour où le général de gaulle et
la foule parisienne et ont porté jean
moulin je parle général de gaulle
souvenons nous de l'accueil que nyon
faire dans toute la france toutes les
générations le français qui voient en
lui
du fond de leurs que l'expression de
leur sentiment national le plus sincère
le plus profond et que dire du 14
juillet c'est l'expression d'un
sentiment unanime
[Musique]
non
les 14 juillet pendant l'occupation
allemande
silencieux dans les villes dans les
moindres communes l'ont bien montré
pourquoi le sentiment de la nation est
il toujours vivant au coeur des français
pour une raison simple le sentiment de
la nation et l'expression des valeurs
essentielles d'accord mischler de donner
l'exemple de la france est une qui un
moment donné à prend une position
fondamentalement d'homme libre de
citoyens is it dont jaar en 41
quand il veut donner l'exemple de
quelqu'un qui dans le pire malheur c'est
à dire la déportation de marque à la
fois sa volonté d'hommes et en même
temps une sorte de fierté français if i
think the bronchard plus lorsque mon
père m'avait dit partout de rire avec
quoi ils m'avaient du fossile va pas de
plus est à terre c'est pas faire pas
terminée donc nourricière
alors
il faudra que tu travailles ponctuent
courante avec l'intérêt avec jacques
ancet d'intérêt général pas mais il
faudra que tu sois quoi la dépendance la
coiffer leurs besoins et où c'est ce que
vous dites vous enfants bien sûr un
christian léon bronchart étape et c'est
lui qui arrivait le cheminot qui a
refusé de conduire
ça va être un déclencheur l'interné 741
regarde le cac40 de guerre inspecteur
chef de dépose que chef de dépôt tout le
monde au pied de la machine
et puis en train de me dire par tous les
moyens pour agir en charge vous êtes un
cheminot modèle car je n'avais jamais
des hauts-pays branchard qu'est ce que
ça veut dire etc
et puis l'autre têtu comme une mule je
vais bien sûr dans toute ma vie j'ai
souffert que la dignité humaine en
général ne soit pas tellement reconnu
vous et est envoyé
j'ai toujours vu que les personnes d'une
plus haute culture d'un plus haut rang
d'appui aux choses et ainsi de suite
pour du mépris mais enfin on tique est
un peu sur le type d'ouvriers et les
ouvriers que je voulais ils remplissent
un rôle dans la vie c'est eux qui
participent à la prospérité de la nation
par leur travail comme par le travail de
tous aussi bien que des lectures et que
d'autres mais moi ma condition d'ouvrier
j'avais à défendre cette
un soldat c'était mon cas des bronches
heures on en rencontre dans tous les
milieux dans toutes les villes et de
tous les âges
consciemment ou non ils savent que la
patrie c'est la liberté des citoyens que
la patrie non c'est la solidarité
nationale pour la patrie enfin c'est
l'unité française
parlons d'abord de la liberté la liberté
cela veut dire aller et venir choisir sa
vie et son métier s'installer à son gré
être satisfaits ou mécontents à son
choix aller à l'église ou ne pas y aller
choisir son opinion en changer c'est
l'ensemble de ces libertés qui font la
valeur de la vie humaine dans une
société est garantie par le libre choix
des dirigeants cette année par la
liberté politique clé est garant de
toutes les autres libertés le fait
pour une minorité après avoir voté
d'être gouvernés par les élus de la
majorité cela représente un mécanisme
dont nous rendons pas compte à quel
point ils supposent une telle solidarité
entre tous que la liberté en est
sauvegardé est assurée c'est l'idée de
nation et l'idée de patrie qui permet ce
gouvernement l'expression du marité
l'indépendance nationale est la
condition de la liberté des citoyens à
garder le dernier exemple et conviendra
ma titre la tchécoslovaquie
le jour où la tchécoslovaquie est entré
sur le chemin de la dépendance
aussitôt tu es née la liberté des
citoyens et du jour où l'indépendance de
la tchécoslovaquie a disparu est morte
la liberté des citoyens
[Musique]
le fils de l'étranger récemment
installés en france devient aussi
français que le paysan dont la famille
est sur la même terre depuis des siècles
le protestant ou le juif sont aussi
français que le catholique oulaté
pasteur est français mais aussi marie
curie née polonaise de la croix est
français mais aussi chagall né russe
jean bouin est français mais aussi
copains les polonais le sentiment de la
nation tels que la france l'a forgé est
un tel sentiment à la fois de tolérance
et de générosité que la patrie française
et le bien de tous aucun lien social
religion race profession n'atteint ce
sens élevé de la vie sociale et c'est
une des gloires de la france qu avoir
enfanté un tel sentiment national que
l'on peut dire est français celui qui
veut être français c'est ainsi par
exemple que se forgent la solidarité il
faut mettre en commun beaucoup d'argent
pour construire des écoles des lycées
des hôpitaux partout des logements pour
tous pour mettre en place sécurité
sociale ou allocations familiales ont
enlevé il sentiments de la nation
enlevez l'idée patrie et vous n'avez
plus de solidarité
pourtant
les français se dispute entre eux
l'école dangers menacent les différences
d'opinion disparaissent c'est côte à
côte que meurent d'estienne d'orves et
un ouvrier boulanger c'est pour la même
cause que meurent mouchotte ou un paysan
prenons quelques grandes heures de notre
histoire volontaires de l'an 2
la longue attente du retour de l'alsace
et la lorraine à la france nous avons vu
récemment sur les écrans
jacquou le croquant s'étend que sur son
lit de mort
l'auteur de ce roman populaire l'auteur
de ce roman de révolte disait lorsque
l'alsace et la lorraine redeviendront
française déposé des fleurs sur ma peau
pensons à l'union sacrée de 1914 à la
résistance de 1944 alors le sentiment
national et cloud est-ce que la légende
embellit la réalité nous sommes nombreux
à avoir vécu
l'unité de la france libre et de la
résistance dans l'extrême diversité des
âges et des conditions dès lors
nous savons que le sentiment national
n'est pas un sentiment du passé il n un
sentiment du présent est à bien des
égards la réalité alors dépasse la
littérature si la patrie et le bien de
tous elle n'est l'apanage de personne
notre france fait l'objet de convoitises
tout au long de notre histoire
l'étranger à chercher des amis dans la
place ses amis pour réussir leurs
entreprises n'ont cessé de clamer leur
patriotisme ce qu'ils ont brûlés jeanne
d'arc pour faire plaisir aux anglais
parlait de l'intérêt de la france
ceux qui se sont opposés henri iv pour
faire plaisir aux espagnols faisait
sonner au leur patriotisme ceux qui
pendant l'occupation collaboré avec les
allemands se disaient les meilleurs des
français et le mensonge sous d'autres
formes
continuant il y a toujours chez nous des
hommes qui ne veulent plus croire en la
france
certains se donnent des excuses au nom
du réalisme d'autres à l'occasion font
profession de patriotisme mais ces
tables c'est notamment le cas des
dirigeants communistes en 1939 ils ont
approuvé le pacte germano soviétique
ce pacte était peut-être utile à la
russie de staline il était mortel pour
la france pour être vraiment patriote il
ne faut avoir aucun fil à la patte et le
fils du parti communiste est une corde
certains s'en moque ou s'en
désintéressent de pâtisseries et des
passes et économiquement et
idéologiquement dans la mesure où
économiquement les groupes de production
nationaux sont pas suffisants pour
remplir la demande marché européen qui
est un marché assez puissant ça fait
environ
1 400 millions d'individus je crois
idéologiquement parce qu'enfin les
européens sont en train de se rendre
compte que malgré quelques différences
qu'on pourrait appeler locale nous
savons qu'ils appartiennent à une entité
morrone politi no zafy et pour voir
parce que il ya toujours une culture
française et c'est un grand atout commun
qui lie entre tous les français
les kings et il ya beaucoup moins entre
tous les pays de l'europe entre un
allemand et un français on trouve très
peu de points communs entre deux
français y a il ya des siècles
d'histoire est la patrie c'est ensemble
d'une culture d'une histoire et tout ça
forme
l'impression générale que ça le patron
regardons autour de nous dans l'union
soviétique envoie un engin sur la lune
quel est le signe que porte cet engin le
drapeau soviétique quand un astronaute
américain dépose un drapeau sur la lune
c'est le drapeau américain
dira-t-on qu'il s'agit de très grande
puissance certes mais la puissance
d'appel l'exclusivité du patriotisme
non ce serait la négation du droit de
chaque peuple à déterminer son destin
houllier d'ailleurs nos voisins hier la
grande bretagne ne voulait pas entrer
dans le marché commun aujourd'hui elle
le veut qu'est-ce qui la déterminent
d'intérêt anglais les allemands sont
divisés que cherche-t-il l'unité de leur
nation actuellement divisé en deux états
selon les termes employés par le
chancelier actuelle mais pas patrie la
division du monde en patrie n'est ce pas
la guerre toutes les tentatives de
coopération internationale pour
préserver la paix ont échoué ou échouent
devant l'intransigeance des nations
la société des nations pendant
l'entre-deux-guerres a fait la
démonstration éclatante de son
impuissance et notamment elle a été tout
à fait incapable d'empêcher hitler 2
d'arriver au pouvoir aujourd'hui
l'onu fait la preuve de son impuissance
un peu partout que ce soit au vietnam
dans la guerre s'éternise que ce soit au
moyen-orient
chaque fois l'onu proteste envoie des
observateurs qui observe quoi la
catastrophe
il ne faut pas confondre nationalisme et
sentiment national home à gary vous avez
écrit le patriotisme c'est d'abord
l'amour des siens
le nationalisme c'est d'abord la haine
des autres oui je lui dire par là que le
patriotisme est essentiellement une
notion d'amour les nageurs de coeur
nationalisme une priorité à la haine
le patriotisme c'est être dans sa peau
comme on est dans son pays
dans son pays comme on est dans sa peau
on est bien on est mal mais on est dans
sa peau tandis que le nationalisme est
une notion de supériorité sur les autres
avec une méconnaissance de l'amour des
autres pour leur propre patrie c'est une
question d'un tag monisme
la nation c'est notre avenir car notre
avenir c'est la liberté des citoyens car
notre avenir c'est la solidarité entre
les citoyens car notre avenir c'est
l'unité française au service du grand
combat des peuples pour la coopération
et la paix en europe et au delà que nos
enfants soient patriotes qu'ils
comprennent qu'ils ont la charge de la
france demain comme hier c'est la france
leurs progrès c'est la france leur
dignité
voilà vous venez d'assister comme nous à
la projection des deux films réalisés
sous la responsabilité de monsieur
michel debré et de monsieur jacques
duclos vous avez pu observer que dans le
film de monsieur jacques duclos le rôle
des capitaux étrangers en france était
mis en cause les animateurs de cette
émission ont donc demandé au président
d'une société française dans laquelle
sont entrés des capitaux étrangers de
répondre et nous avons en direct
monsieur georges et rei monsieur
caravelle qui est le président de simca
dans laquelle la firme américaine
chrysler a des intérêts très importants
monsieur georges oreilles
n'entendez-vous fort bien alors à vous
eh bien j'ai été frappée tout à l'heure
lorsque écoutant dans le film de jacques
duclos un ouvrier
deux ouvriers un ingénieur deux
ingénieurs de voir une préoccupation
très vive et je dirais touchante
lorsque ils ont senti l'un et l'autre
que la disposition de lusine ou des
moyens techniques de recherche qui
étaient les leurs passés dans des mains
étrangères
en fait je veux les rassurer pleinement
car je considère que nous sommes entrés
maintenant dans un monde des changes ou
des f
des événements comme celui ci peuvent se
passer et se passait relativement
fréquemment mais pas naturellement à
sens unique
je dis tout de suite que ses
investissements dans le monde des
échanges qui est le nôtre
au moment où l'on parle d'ordinateur ou
le moment où l'on voit des pas sur la
lune
au moment de toutes les communications
télé spéciale nous pouvons pas parler
que nous allons rester entre nous dans
une forteresse bien fermé bien
verrouiller les verrous de la géographie
saute souvent et ce qui est important
c'est qu'à l'intérieur d'une nation à
l'intérieur d'un pays avec le
patriotisme de chacun
ce pays se développent et accepte comme
c'est normal sous son contrôle l'effort
d'autres l'effort des capitaux l'effort
de techniciens aussi l'effort de
recherche et en définitive participent à
ce développement des échanges
internationaux
il est hors de doute que si nous
examinons la question de capitaux
étrangers
je le répète soumis à un contrôle
national évident nous pouvons nous
rendre compte de tout le rôle qu'ils
peuvent jouer du développement auxquels
ils peuvent nous aider
et en définitive quel est le risque où
est-il le risque est il pour nous au
contraire pour ses capitaux étrangers et
sans entrer dans la polémique
on pourrait se souvenir de l'époque
14-18 où la france avait des capitaux
investis à l'étranger sous forme de bons
et on sait malheureusement ce qu'il en
est devenu pour beaucoup
actuellement le risque donc n'existe pas
ni pour les travailleurs ni pour les
ingénieurs
karine sont pas téléguidée ils sont sur
le territoire national ils pensent
justement avec le sens patriotique dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure à la
création à la fabrication au
développement tout ceci c'est à nous
c'est à la france alors en définitive je
considère en ce qui concerne que nous
sommes dans le monde des échanges nous y
sommes définitivement c'est le monde du
progrès la france a un rôle à jouer
nous n'avons pas redouter d'être
colonisés disons les choses telles
qu'elles sont la france est souvent
difficile à gouverner mais certainement
impossible à coloniser voilà ce que je
peux dire est en tout cas je pense que
nous allons maintenant vers la grande
patrie et ce sera toujours la patrie des
hommes
je vous remercie les téléspectateurs
sont également pu remarquer que dans le
film de monsieur michel debré c'était
l'organisation des nations unies qui
était mise en cause est mis en cause
notamment dans l'intervention de jean
cau de la même façon donc à propos du
film de monsieur jacques duclos
les animateurs de cette émission ont
demandé à monsieur su le berger qui est
éditorialiste du quotidien américain new
york times et qui suit depuis très
longtemps ses problèmes de nous répondre
alors il est très facile a souligné
n'est ce pas les défauts du l'onu je
n'ai pas jamais ne s'est pas fait ni
l'organisation mondiale
mais il ne faut pas oublier les aspects
positifs par exemple le ch et on peut
dire c'est une ré positif voire pour des
questions insolubles ou un peu au moins
évité des grandes guerres il y a
toujours des petites guerres mais il ya
ces jours une différence entre le
désastre total et même des pierres
sauvages comme au moyen orient où le
vietnam et deuxièmement il y a deux
temps j'entends j'attends des moments où
l'on eut peu était par exemple encore et
je crois que c'était grâce à l'onu qu'on
a trouvé une formule pour répondre à une
agression elle aussi à la langue pour
résoudre cette question le congo ce
n'était pas un succès formidable mais
grâce à l'onu on a évité le chaos total
mais peut-être je cois l'aspect le plus
intéressant dans palm à l'heure
mon le moins cher le fait que au
quartier général de l'onu il ya des
moyennes pour des conférences secrètes
entre des diplomates de n'importe quel
côté communiste anti communiste du sud
du nord
il ya des contacts presque permanent
compact jean pellet contact aujourd'hui
entre les quatre grands sur les
questions du moyen orient alors c'est la
ga table que ça ne marche pas plus
dramatiquement n'est ce pas dans le sens
positif mais ça c'est à quelque chose
malgré tout est déjà à l'existence du
l'onu se passe
l'existence de la société des nations et
peut-être grâce à ce fait seuls
l'obligation devient peut-être un peu
moins faible
je n'ai pas encore le jour de dire plus
fort mais il faudra regarder les choses
comme elles sont vous avez maintenant à
peu près tous les éléments du dossier
sauf un qui je crois est essentiel et
qui vous permettra de mieux suivre le
débat tout à l'heure entre monsieur
debré monsieur duclos c'est à savoir que
pensent les français de l'idée de patrie
la sofres qui est un organisme de
sondage a effectué une enquête nationale
et pierre weill qui est à mes côtés qui
le directeur de la sofres pas 20 ans
vous en présenter les résultats
le sondage dont les résultats vont vous
être présenté dans un instant a été
réalisé par la sofres au cours de la
première semaine de février auprès d'un
échantillon national de 1000 français
représentatifs de l'ensemble des
français âgés de 21 ans et plus vous
savez que la particularité de ce sondage
réside dans le fait que les questions
ont été formulées pour moitié par
monsieur michel debré et pour moitié par
monsieur jacques duclos ce sont eux
quelque sorte qu'ils se sont fait
sondeurs d'opinion ce qui explique sans
doute la formulation un peu inhabituel
de certaines questions en ce qui
concerne la présentation des résultats
différents renseignements vous seront
donnés notamment l'auteur de la question
michel debré ou jacques duclos
les pourcentages sur l'ensemble des
français et les pourcentages concernant
deux catégories qui compte tenu du débat
de ce soir nous intéresse
particulièrement les électeurs
communistes et les électeurs du dr les
questions ont été regroupées en trois
rubriques première rubrique qu'on peut
appeler conception générale du
patriotisme c'est une rubrique qui se
compose exclusivement de questions
posées par monsieur michel debré on y
relève un large accord de tous les
français pour reconnaître l'importance
du fait national de ce point de vue
d'ailleurs les réponses les électeurs
idr et des électeurs communistes vont
tout à fait dans le même sens
la deuxième rubrique on peut appeler
patriotisme et patronat se compose de
trois questions posées tout les 3 par
monsieur jacques duclos
on y relève également un accord assez
large de tous les français pour
suspecter le patriotisme du patronat
dont on sait par ailleurs les sondages
qu'il a relativement mauvaise presse en
france les réponses des lecteurs idr des
électeurs communistes vont encore dans
le même sens mais cette fois les
électeurs communistes et c'est évident
sont nettement plus critique à l'égard
du patronat enfin la troisième rubrique
on prend trois questions de questions
posées par monsieur jacques duclos une
question posée par monsieur michel debré
et concerne l'appréciation de la
politique actuelle du gouvernement
cette fois comme il est naturel les
réponses des électeurs eu des airs
s'opposent nettement à celle des
électeurs communistes y avait je vous
arrête je ne souhaite pas qu il y ait
trop de détails car maintenant vous
allez être exposé en détail les
résultats mais ni monsieur debré ni
monsieur duclos ne vont les connaître
nous tenons en effet ce que seule tête
les téléspectateurs dispose de ce moyen
de référence et de comparaison afin que
ni monsieur debré ni monsieur duclos
n'intègre dans leur raisonnement les
arguments que pourrait leur apporter les
résultats des sondages
nous n'allons pas vous rendez les yeux
monsieur du préau mais le studio tout ce
plateau
va être comme on dit offre à partir de
maintenant première question si on vous
demandait de vous définir par une
caractéristique quelle est celle que
vous choisiriez sur la liste suivante
eh bien on constate que le fait d'être
français vient largement en tête 42 %
les autres caractéristiques telles que
âge profession classes sociales et
cetera son site et chacune par moins de
20% des français
deuxième question estimez vous qu'il est
très important
assez important peu important ou pas
important du tout cas l'école les jeunes
français d'aujourd'hui apprennent à
aimer la france une quasi unanimité les
français considèrent qu'il est très
important que l'école enseigne le
patriotisme
de ce point de vue cette valeur ne
paraisse certainement pas démodé
troisième question avez vous le
sentiment que si la france renoncé à son
indépendance
cela aurait des conséquences plutôt
favorable plutôt défavorables ou pas de
conséquence du tout sur votre liberté
les français ont nettement le sentiment
que l'indépendance nationale et la
garantie de leur liberté
de même si l'on examine les résultats de
la question suivante on voit bien qu'une
majorité relie indépendance nationale et
niveau de vie mais sans doute est-ce -
l'intégration dans le marché commun que
la colonisation par les grandes
puissances économiques que les français
redoutent ainsi cinquième question dans
l'ensemble estimez vous que le patronat
français fait plutôt passer ses intérêts
financiers avant l'intérêt national 73%
ou l'intérêt national avant ses intérêts
financiers 11 % sans opinion 16% sixième
question après la dévaluation du franc
estimez vous que le gouvernement
français n'a pas entrepris une lutte
suffisante contre la spéculation 58% ou
a pris des mesures suffisantes contre la
spéculation 22 % sans opinion 20%
on constate que même parmi les électeurs
idr il se trouve une majorité pour
regretté que le gouvernement n'ait pas
été plus sévère à l'égard des profits
réalisés par les spéculateurs
lors de la dévaluation du franc 7e
question estimez vous préférez
luck est la principale entreprise
française fabriquant des avions
militaires soit une entreprise privée
24% ou une entreprise nationalisée 53 %
sans opinion 23%
ici encore large accord en faveur de la
nationalisation mais pour les uns il
s'agit sans doute de remettre en cause
la propriété privée des moyens de
production alors que pour les autres il
s'agit peut-être d'assurer le contrôle
de la nation sur ses moyens de défense
8e question estimez-vous que le
gouvernement actuel défend avant tout
les intérêts du patronat 45% les
intérêts de tous les français sans
distinction 32% les intérêts des
travailleurs 8 % sans opinion 15%
on voit que 85% des électeurs
communistes lee l'action gouvernementale
aux intérêts du patronat
alors que 54% des électeurs eu des airs
pense que cette action profite à tous
les français neuvièmes question dans le
domaine de l'utilisation industrielle de
l'énergie atomique
le gouvernement vient récemment de
donner la préférence un procédé
américains sur un procédé français en ce
qui concerne cette affaire avec laquelle
des deux opinions suivante êtes vous le
plus d'accord le gouvernement a eu
raison pour des motifs économiques 36%
le gouvernement a eu tort car cela porte
atteinte à l'indépendance nationale 25 %
sans opinion 39%
là encore on constate une opposition
très nette entre les électeurs
communistes d'une part et les électeurs
eu des erreurs d'autres pas 10e et
dernière question dans la conduite de
leur politique étrangère
certains pays se soucie d'abord de
rester fidèles à leurs principes
d'autres se préoccupe avant tout de
leurs intérêts de puissances parmi les
quatre pays suivants quel est celui qui
vous semblent se soucier le plus de
rester fidèle à ses principes
on voit que les électeurs communistes
place l'union soviétique nettement en
tête alors que pour les électeurs du dr
c'est la france est de loin qui est la
plus fidèle à ses principes
en revanche tous les français sont
d'accord pour estimer que les états unis
font passer leurs intérêts avant leurs
principes
voilà tout est en place tout est en
place pour le deuxième round
c'est à dire pour le débat proprement
dit entre monsieur michel debré monsieur
jacques duclos débat que va maintenant
animée jacques et alain duhamel
merci c'est monsieur michel debré qui a
gagné le toss et qui a donc pu
déterminer l'ordre du passage des films
c'est donc puisque nous sommes armes
égales
monsieur jacques duclos qui va pouvoir
le premier à prendre la parole
oui j'ai pas mal de choses à dire sur le
film de muscu dubaï mais tout d'abord
j'ai quelque chose à dire sur la
déclaration faite par monsieur est
revenu au nom de tous les pdg de france
et de navarre défendre le caractère
cosmopolite de capital et bien lui
prétend qu'il n'y a aucun danger à voir
le capital étranger s'introduire en
france et il prétend que ces mêmes
l'avenir et que par conséquent l'idée de
patrick de secret tels que cela
l'imaginent monsieur debré est appelée à
disparaître assez rapidement parce qu'il
ya contradiction entre ce que disait ce
monsieur rei et l'alluré générale de
votre film en face ça c'est une autre
histoire ici quelques chiffres me
paraissent importants la page je veux
montrer qu'en france il ya des régions
entières qui sont sous industrialisés et
tandis qu'il ya des capitaux français
qui viennent sont les capitaux étrangers
qui viennent sa veste il en france il ya
aussi des capitaux français qui sont
investis à l'étranger et par exemple
saint gobain
on a beaucoup parlé de saint gobain
derrière avec riboud et d'évoluer et
bien la part de production en france de
la compagnie saint gobain est tombé de
49 à 42 % les dix dernières années pour
que la france le ca la part des pays
étrangers dans le chiffre d'affaires de
la compagnie française des pétroles et
de 24,5 pour cent l'air liquide dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
parce que c'était une société qui a fait
pas mal de bénéfices pendant
l'occupation italienne en france l'air
liquide à plus de la moitié de son
capital et 60 disposant de son personnel
à l'étranger l'échiné prévoir qu'en 1973
ses usines américaines et hollandaises
produiront optant d'aluminium que toutes
ses usines françaises et michelin
d'après la presse financière réalise un
chiffre d'affaires supérieur à
l'étranger qu'en france et les ciments
lafarge réaliste aussi plus tard fred
aux états unis qu'en france il alors si
on regarde les noms financiers dans la
financière de suez capitaux anglais la
banque de rothschild alors liaison entre
la banque française et anglaise belle
américaine l'union européenne
industrielles et financières banques du
groupe schneider pénétration de capitaux
américains qui détiennent une banque
américaine qui le 10 à 20 % des capitaux
la banque commerciale de paris du groupe
dassault dont monsieur chalandon était
naguère le directeur a cédé 15% et 10%
de participation à une banque américaine
de la banque allemande
quatre banques anglaises allemandes et
américaines dès 13 ans 69 50 % du
capital de la banque
valence 4e banque d'affaires française
contrôlée en grande partie par la
famille étage et je constate que les
milieux gaullistes à part est en
relation très étroite avec ces groupes
financiers qui sont fortement pénétrer
par le capital étranger par l'effet
rothschild je ne veux pas citer le nom
d'un père vous avez dû veut pas dassault
lui même et chalandon 116 evans la
famille est en jeu
voilà par conséquent des choses qui ne
sont pas à dédaigner
et puis si on regarde les
investissements américains en france en
1970 deux milliards de dollars dans 2000
ans dans 2000 entreprises réalisant un
chiffre d'affaires annuel de 15 mille
francs de 15 milliards de francs ont été
investis et les capitaux américains
contrôlent en france 85% de l'industrie
française des lames de rasoir 76 % des
ordinateurs 70% des machines à coudre
80% des tracts voilà quelques chiffres
qui montrent de ce monsieur et rei
lorsqu ils minimisent l'importance et le
danger que représente la pénétration de
capitaux étrangers en france se moquent
gentiment du monde monsieur du que vous
je crois de répondre à monsieur et je
pense donc à cette belle que j'ai
répondu saint-pierre et c'est ce que je
vous ai dit monsieur debré vous donc
peut-être vous également pouvoir
répondre à monsieur sus berger je
répondrai pour ce qui me concerne plus
plus brièvement la défense qu'a fait
monsieur sus berger de l'onu n'est pas
mauvaise mais elle est elle cache bien
les choses
par exemple elle cache le fait que cette
organisation a décidé que lorsqu'il y
aurait un conflit entre états américains
aux rousses une c'est l'organisation des
états américains qui sont en occuperait
est pas le nu que lorsqu'il y aurait un
conflit en afrique c'est l'organisation
de l'union africaine est pas le nu par
conséquent on ne s'occupe pas du biafra
pas plus qu'on ne s'est occupé de saint
domingue qu'on ne s'occupe pas davantage
de ce qui se passe en russie et chez les
satellites et on ne s'occupe pas de
budapest c'est à dire que déjà toute une
partie du monde échappe à une
organisation internationale
et j'ajoute qu'il y a eu une fois où
l'organisation des nations unies
auraient peut-être pu sauver la paix
c'est lorsque gouvernement égyptien a
demandé le départ des casques bleus de
les maintenir ou de les doubler
et peut-être ça aurait été la fin ou en
tout cas ce qu'on n'aurait pas été le
commencement de la guerre des six jours
dont nous connaissons toutes les suites
aujourd'hui en d'autres termes
l'organisation des nations unies est une
institution une institution respectable
ou comme l'a dit monsieur sud berger le
grand rêve de la diplomatie publique se
transforme en salle réservée à la
diplomatie secrète si on veut faire du
travail utile mais ce qui est le fond
des choses c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme
hier une nation pacifique qui veut
garder son indépendance et à travers son
indépendance ces libertés est obligé de
compter sur elle même et de ne pas
compter sur l'organisation des nations
unies qui n'a en aucune façon la
capacité de maintenir la paix et la
liberté
c'est ça que vous voulez dire jean cau
c'est ça que je veux dire
l'institution est bonne mais elle
n'empêche pas les nations de sur grande
elle même de se considérer elle même
comme responsable de
leur destin puisque vous avez au fond
répondu l'un et l'autre à vos
contestataires je pense que maintenant
monsieur jacques duclos va pouvoir être
ainsi nous donner ses premières
réactions sur le film réalisé c'est la
responsabilité de michel debré je vais
tout d'abord remarqué des choses c'est
monsieur michel devait à posséder un
amalgame assez dangereux et qui me
touchent directement c'est pourquoi je
vais à réagir avec non moins de vigueur
j'ai vu des images on a passé le traître
doriot qui faisait partie de la
cinquième colonne hitlérienne qui était
au service du préfet rangeront pendant
la drôle de guerre pour nous pour
chasser ils étaient payés par la banque
rothschild justement de beat un livre
qui vient de paraître ces jours derniers
chez fayard que mon éditeur est bien
mais je ne suis pour rien mais c est
bien ce doriot vous l'avez pas c'est là
et vous avez essayé de faire la malle
dame entre les dirigeants communistes et
comme j'en suis un je me sens
directement concerné alors
expliquons-nous et tartas allons au fond
du problème
vous avez parlé du pacte germano
soviétique et bien quand on parle du
pacte germano soviétique il faut essayer
de voir le contexte dans lequel les
choses se sont passées quelle était la
politique suivie par la france dans
cette période là la france avait
abandonné l'espagne républicaine ce qui
était intrigué il est volontaire
français qui sont partis en espagne
dépendre la l'espagne dépendent est en
vérité la dépendance française
et puis il y a eu milic munich
on a présenté sa commune victoire de la
france comme une victoire de la paix
c'était la plus sombre des capitulations
que l'on ait pu imaginer
d'ailleurs daladier lui-même quand il
est revenu a été surpris des
acclamations qui n'accueillait ils
savaient très bien lui qui n'avait pas
sauvé la paix il avait au contraire
compromis gravement la sécurité de la
france et puis l'accord de munich a été
suivi de l'accord franco allemand de
décembre 1938 et c'est dans cette
période là que jean pierre bonnet avait
dit à l'ambassadeur d'allemagne dès le
compte d' el cheikh il y avait 10 les
communistes seront
mise à la raison et puis finalement le
comité france allemagne agissait comme
il le voulait et lorsque les la
délégation militaire franco britannique
s'est rendu à moscou
elle n'a pas accepté de prendre des
dispositions en vue d'obtenir un accord
militaire puisse être efficace
à la vérité la pologne des colonels et
la roumanie ne voulait pas laisser
passer les armées soviétiques sur leur
territoire c'est dans ces conditions là
et maintenant les documents de monsieur
neville chamberlain qui viennent d'être
publiées à londres montre de façon
encore plus clair qu'elles étaient le
double jeu du gouvernement anglais et de
gouvernement français le jeu du
gouvernement anglais et de gouvernement
français c'était de faire se battre
l'union soviétique élite l'air et
ensuite pour pouvoir tirer les marrons
du feu
et dans cet internat dans cette
affaire-là eh bien lorsque l'union
soviétique a pris cette décision de
signer le traité avec l'allemagne le
pacte germano soviétique qui n'était pas
un traité d'alliance qui était un traité
de non agression
c'était la politique française cherche
lui-même l'a reconnu ce la politique
française et anglaise qu'il avait acculé
à 7,6 place non et alors vous nous
présenter en somme comme de mauvais
français
vous essayez de vous présenter comme des
trans est assez singulier des français
de deuxième zone
et bien là il faut s'expliquer no nous
avons été pourchassés ma tête a été mise
à prix j'ai été condamné
nous la pl peine de mort ces surnoms ne
vont pas plancher n'avons pas été de
ceux de ceux qui se renie est aux
fourneaux révolue on aurait voulu nous
faire oublier nos idées ont évolué que
nous allions demander l'amant et dire
nous cessons d'être communiste
aujourd'hui nous sommes pas à ma
personne vous savez la morgue nous fait
pas peur et c'est dans ces conditions là
nous avons continué à lutter et lorsque
la france a été envahi nous avons été là
pour la défendre et nous avons été pas
les derniers je ne dis pas vous avance
était seul et ne vont pas été les
derniers à la défendre
monsieur
je voudrais d'abord dire ceci je suis
ici le seul ministre et monsieur duclos
et de l'opposition je pense que les
opinions dans ce studio et autour des
postes de télévision sont diverses et
nous discutons du patriotisme mais
jamais l'hypothèse monsieur duclos chef
du gouvernement aux ministres serions
nous ici à discuter du patriotisme je ne
le pense pas car l'une des lumières
catégores quatre caractéristiques c'est
que le patriotisme de monsieur duclos
est extrêmement exclusif il est exclu
qu'on le voit bien on est patriotes sous
la révolution il a raison on est
patriotes sous la commune
il a raison mais l'histoire du
patriotisme français est une longue
histoire à travers tous les régimes
le patriotisme et le bien de tous il
n'est l'apanage de personne
et d'autre part il n'est pas non plus
l'apanage d'un des dirigeants du parti
communiste pcc a dû annuler jamais 17 au
gouvernement je ne suis absolument pas
certain que nous puissions discuter
comme nous l'avons discuté aujourd'hui
maintenant autres et pour consulter sa
base du lait au chocolat ou succès je
suppose
est ce que vous venez de dire donne un
certain encouragement à ma question
qu'au lieu de faire ce film en 1970 vous
nous lution fait mettons en 1934 en 1939
ou en 1948 supposer qu'on nous demande
de le faire dans dix ans
pensez vous que la manière dont vous
présenteriez les choses seraient là même
nom parce que non seulement vous avez
une conception restrictive du
patriotisme mais vous avez en plus le
sentiment que comme il y à une doctrine
sociale une doctrine dite sociale qui
vous conduit à une doctrine politique
d'alignement votre patriotisme est lié à
une question fondamentale nous sommes
nationaux dans la mesure où la défense
des intérêts français convient à
l'intérêt soviétique haletante
il est je crois
important au début de cette discussion
de bien marquer ces deux caractères de
ce film est de votre film encore une
fois soyez heureux que je sois ministre
et pas vous et soyez heureux également
qu'on vous ait demandé ce film en 1970
est pas il y a dix ans et peut-être pas
dans quelques années
voilà je levais le frij du point le film
justement dont je me suis servi au début
de ce livre nous avez vu c'est la
marseillaise
eh bien voyez-vous notre patriotisme
nedap n'est pas une chose occasionnels
ce film j'ai travaillé avec jean renoir
à ce moment là non pas comme si d art
mais j'ai discuté avec lui pour faire ce
film la marseillaise parce que le
gouvernement de l'époque ne se
préoccupait pas de célébrer le 150e
anniversaire de la révolution française
nous l'avons en quelque sorte remplacé
mais revenons maintenant à nos moutons
revenons à la résistance revenons au
patriotisme
non nous avons été pourchassés par des
gouvernants comme vous parce que vous
étiez vous dans le cabinet de paul
reynaud à ce moment là bon et bien à ce
moment là eh bien vous êtes parti c'est
bien lorsque la guerre a été électrisé
vous êtes allés au front
bon mais pendant cette période là vous
avez été dans ce gouvernement où les
campagnes anti communistes étaient
concernés on essayait de créer un climat
de programmes contre nous n'est-ce pas
eh bien lorsque la guerre a été là nous
avons nous nous avons lutté contre à
weissach allemand est ici et ici vous
m'entendez bien je vais vous citer
puisque vous êtes gaulliste à taux plein
vous et je vous cite et une lettre une
lettre que j'ai reçue en tant que
dirigeant puisse être réparé des
dirigeants communistes français est bien
en tant que dirigeant du parti
communiste
j'ai reçu le 10 février 1904 daté du 10
février à l'emploi adressée au comité
central du parti communiste français
la lettre suivante l'arrivée de fernand
grenier l'adhésion du parti communiste
au comité national qu'il m'a apporté à
votre nom la mise à ma disposition en
tant que chef des forces françaises des
vaillantes formation de francs-tireurs
que vous avez constituer et animer
voilà une nouvelle preuve de votre
volonté de contribuer à la libération et
grandeur de notre pays convaincu que
votre décision apporte une contribution
importante à l'international je vous en
remercie sincèrement de grands efforts
de grands sacrifices vous seront
demandés après tout ce que les membres
de votre parti ont déjà consenti au
service de la france et bien à ce moment
là c'était à la fin 2009 cette année
datent du début de 43 42
nous nous battions depuis longtemps déjà
en 41 ans 41
il y avait tous les fusillés de
châteaubriant monsieur duclos oui
monsieur duclos oui nous discutons sur
la patrie et le patriote et bien sachez
que j'étais je peux si vous voulez
revenir à juin 40 et à l'allusion que
vous avez vous même faites dans vos
mémoires de certains dirigeants comme
communiste demandant aux allemands la
parution de l'humanité je pourrais
également citer aussi bien d'autres
ouvrages qui montrent que si un certain
nombre individuellement ont été
courageux jusqu'en juin 41
le parti communiste a pris une certaine
position à partir du moment où
l'allemagne hitlérienne et par envahi la
rue si ce n'est pas vrai l'histoire moi
je dis que vous avez fait traîner les
cheveux je voudrais vous voyez ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que je pense
que la discussion sur le sens de la
patrie est une discussion qui doit être
tourné vers l'avenir
nous avons chacun l'héritage du passé
français mais regardons pourquoi en 1970
vis-à-vis des jeunes générations
sommes nous les défenseurs de la patrie
sommes-nous je parle de ceux qui pensent
comme moi mais encore une fois il n'ya
point de monopole du patriotisme
pourquoi pensons-nous qu'il faut être
patriote et c'est là peut-être où vous
ne répondez pas il faut être patriote
parce que l'essentiel de la vie humaine
c'est la liberté
c'est à dire
la possibilité pour chaque homme et pour
chaque femme citoyens citoyennes d'avoir
sa liberté d'opinion mais je parle youth
et sa liberté et pour pouvoir défendre
ses libertés il faut un régime politique
fondé sur le suffrage universel
librement exprimée jeudi bien libre
lundi dans libération d'un camp de vie
librement exprimée et pour avoir ce
suffrage universel il faut une
solidarité si grande que au lendemain du
scrutin
ceux qui n'ont pas été élus ce dont les
candidats n'ont pas été élues s'incline
devant la loi de la majorité
c'est ce mécanisme extrêmement délicat
et qu'on ne connaît que dans une faible
partie du monde qui donne à la notion de
patrie à la notion de nation sa valeur
éternelle
c'est cela l'essentiel et quand nous
nous tournons vers les jeunes
c'est cela que nous devons leur
apprendre et que nous devons leur faire
comprendre
en outre c'est ainsi que sa firme à
l'égard de toutes les forces du monde
l'indépendance d'une nation et ses
possibilités de faire triompher
non seulement ces intérêts matériels
mais aussi ses vues voilà me semble t'il
l'essentiel du débat et la valeur de
l'idée de patrie je voudrais que vous
répondiez naturellement mais si vous
devriez bien si vous le voulez bien il
faut pas favorisé par un doublé avant
d'être absolument pas à armes égales
ce n'est absolument pas dans l'intention
j'aimerais tout simplement que sur ce
point historique vous compliquez
naturellement
vous les voyez en tenant compte aussi de
l'heure et du fait que je suis sûr que
vous voulez vous même abondé il faut
d'autres aspects du sujet il faut que je
revienne un peu en arrière je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure de la situation de
la france en 1941 1942
en 1942 il y avait un chef de
gouvernement qui s'appelait laval ce
chef de attendu ce chef de gouvernement
avait engagé une campagne à ce moment là
pour échanger un prisonnier france et en
allemagne contre trois travailleurs nous
luttions à cette époque-là contre la
déportation du travail contre cet envoi
de prisonniers français
l'écouté est ici attendait mais ici je
vois j'ai la photocopie du journal
officiel de l'état français du 9 août
1942 et je lis la dent cette page à
l'arrêté en date du 4 août 1942
monsieur michel debré auditeurs de
première classe au conseil d'état est
nommé maître des requêtes au conseil
d'état
forcément de monsieur plus j'ai nommé
conseiller d'état
eh bien vous savez nous n'étions pas à
même nous est d'avoir des nominations
l'un sujet du cloud lycée répondre
monsieur morel devrait bien que ce soit
une question la règle du conseil d'état
et l'avancement à l'ancienneté et les
collègues du conseil d'état était
suffisamment est du genre pour ne pas
faire attention que ma présence au
conseil d'état était tout à fait
hypothétique et proposer des mécanismes
a permis une nomination qui était tout à
fait pour quelqu'un qui ne siégeait
points à ce conseil pour des raisons qui
n'était pas éloignée de celle qui vous
mettait dans la clandestinité bière
d'ailleurs dit vous même
oui mais le gouvernement de l'époque
enfin ne vous pourchasser pas promis
nous pourchasse est à nous alors oui le
sens heine vous allez pas nommé si vous
voulez nous les allemands suffisait à me
pour choisi web et bien nous allions les
deux avions les lunettes mesure est il
que si vous le voulez bien
si vous le voulez bien je crois que j'ai
moi je veux dire que la patrie tels que
la consomment ce debré c'est une patrie
de rêve
c'est une pratique qui n'existe pas dans
la réalité parce que dans un pays comme
la france il y à des hommes qui sont
exploités et il y en a d'autres qui
exploite et entre ces hommes qui sont
exploitées ceux qui exploitent
il n'y a pas identité d'intérêt et c'est
pourquoi notre patriotisme anneaux
consiste à tout bétonner
pour l'essayer de débarrasser la france
de la domination des monopoles
capitalistes dont le gouvernement fait
la politique justement et pour délivrer
la france de la domination des monopoles
capitalistes et bien il faut
naturellement que nous allions vers un
régime nouveau et vers des
nationalisations
par exemple vous parlez de la grandeur
de la france nous admettons nous
parfaitement qu'il faut et une commande
il n mettre la france à l'heure actuelle
du point de vue de son équipement
industriel
mais ce n'est pas dans ce sens combat et
dans la mesure où il ya des
concentrations
ces concentrations se font au détriment
de la place au ciel tandis que nous
tandis que nous pensons que la
nationalisation c'est la forme la plus
démocratique de la concentration qui
exige qu'ils exigent les le
développement de la société à l'heure
actuelle et nous pensons qu'il faut
mettre un terme à la domination des
monopoles capitalistes
vous ne me ferez pas croire que les
monopoles capitalistes sont indépendants
sont indispensables à la vie de la
france tandis que vous aimez écouter les
monopoles capitalistes sont encore moins
utiles que le parti qu ils sont
dangereux ils sont dangereux mais
écoutez si nous n'étions pas là vous
alliez trop beau jeu pour faire votre
politique réactionnaire
je dirais simplement que les
d'importantes nationalisation ont été
réalisées ou l'idée leur est batteur on
voulait des faits ont été réalisés par
le général de gaulle et que ces
nationalisations la plus forte
manifestation du parti communiste est
démultiplié les grèves à caractère
politique
je ne crois pas que ce soit comme ça que
l'on donne à l'ensemble des français le
sentiment que les entreprises
nationalisées sont au service de l'état
je suis très frappé du fait que certains
dirigeants communistes considère que les
entreprises nationales sont le lieu où
l'on peut le plus faire des grèves pour
des motifs non professionnels dans ces
conditions il y as peut-être quelque
chose à modifier à votre jugement
et si vous êtes si favorable au
développement des nationalisations
c'est parce que vous pensez que vous
pourrez multiplier les grèves paul
verlande ce n'est blanc en tout cas les
faits sont là il me semble par ailleurs
que vous venez de dire quelque chose qui
est assez grave et qui est assez grave
dans la mesure où un très grand public
nous écoutent et qui est le suivant
toutes les concentrations se ferait aux
dépens des travailleurs
comment pouvez vous dire cela si il y à
quelques années on avait laissé par
exemple toutes les petites sociétés
d'aviation qui existait jamais on
n'aurait fait concorde c'est parce que
il y a eu six d'aviation concentration
et qui a permis de faire concorder si
c'est semaine dernière j'ai proposé au
gouvernement qui l'a accepté une fusion
plus importante encore c'est parce que
si nous voulons que dans cinq ans dans
dix ans dans 15 ans il y est encore une
industrie aéronautique
il faut une certaine dimension j'ai
entendu parlé tout à l'heure de
quelqu'un qui évoqué l'achat de boules
pourquoi n'at-il pas dit que deux ans
après j'ai proposé au gouvernement et au
général de l'onlcdt ils ont accepté le
plan calcul qui fait qu'il ya maintenant
une société entièrement française avec
les capitaux d'état et des capitaux
privés
en d'autres termes les forts pour
développer la capacité industrielle de
la france est sur ce point si je ne les
trouve pas tout à fait les thèses de
monsieur héreil il a raison avec des
capitaux qui le cas échéant vient ici
apporter les chances de leurs techniques
et leurs possibilités donne une
possibilité à la france de se développer
l'essentiel l'essentiel pour que la
patrie subsiste c'est que le pouvoir
politique soit non seulement
indépendants comme on dit mais qu'il
soit plus fort et si nous avons nous
autres derrière le général de gaulle
tellement travaillé pour que la france
moderne et des institutions qui assurent
l'autorité du chef de l'état et la
stabilité du gouvernement c'est parce
que nous savions qu'il y avait une
nécessité pour le développement
économique des changes multiples de
transformation et qu'il fallait pour le
bien de la france comme pour le bien des
travailleurs qu'il y ait un pouvoir
politique représentant l'intérêt
national qu'il y est ici
là des erreurs il y en a partout mais je
les dirige l'ordi gallery soi mais
l'essentiel est là c'est que dans le
développement de la france qui est
nécessairement un développement porte
ouverte il y ait une autorité politique
qui soit là pour dire l'intérêt national
permet ce si l'intérêt national ne
permet pas cela et cet intérêt national
tous les exemples monde c'est d'abord
l'intérêt des travailleurs et des
ingénieurs russes tu es via voilà vous
voulez parler justement de l'aviation
vous venez de constituer n'ya pas
longtemps une société nationale
aérospatiale
vous avez fait jeûner c'est la version
de l'aviation et ses rêves seulement il
ya un grand producteur d'avion un grand
producteur d'avion qui vit justement
dans l'entreprise vis de fonds publics
cet entrepreneur d'avion c'est dassault
et bien je ne comprends pas qu'il n'ait
pas été intégrés qui n'est pas été
nationalisée est intégré dans cette
société là où le maire c'est pour vous
laisser quelque chose en fait dans cette
société nationale aérospatial non je
vous dire pourquoi au fond vous allez
vous même votre l'égalité en
nationalisant pâle usines dassault
dassault et députés il est en même temps
fournisseurs de l'état
une ordonnance gaulliste interdite peut
on puisse cumuler le mandat de député
avec la fonction de directeur de société
ou d'administrateurs de sociétés
fournissant l'état mais ce que dassault
fait tout cela et et puis monsieur
dassault je le dis un jour à votre quad
buteur monsieur fronton au sénat il n'a
pas bronché ça et je lui ai dit je lui
ai dit je lui ai dit fais aussi
impassible sont les attentes
on raconte que si une des raisons pour
lesquelles ce muscle d'assaut que riche
à milliards qui a bâti sont également là
bas dans les yvelines
ce monsieur là une des raisons pour
lesquelles lui dr ne veut pas
nationalisées d'assaut c'est parce que
par le canal de dassault des fonds
publics passerait dans la pièce
électorale de l'ue dr je pense que vous
ne croyez pas à b assange les bourgs
ajustements je leur loi mais si je le
voulais et je vais vous le croyez pas
c'est justement que l'on va vous ne
voulez pas
l'alizé nassau à la vérité vous voyez
bien vous avez des principes mais vous
les piétiner allégrement nous également
non ce que je trouve pour le meneur du
jeu c'est que me semble-t-il
les auditeurs doivent s'attendre à autre
chose que ce que nous disons maintenant
ils s'attendent en effet car le fond du
problème varela non pas telle ou telle
conception nez ou telle défense
mais pourquoi encore une fois l'ensemble
des français au jour nous sommes pense
ou doit penser selon moi que la patrie
est encore une nécessité pour le parti
communiste la patrie en réalité est un
moyen comme il a prise à l'appel au
peuple que le sentiment national fort
heureusement est très fort dans le
peuple français on dissimule derrière le
mot patriote nice on dissimule derrière
et le patriotisme
une politique qui est une politique
ouverte d'allégeance à une très grande
puissance
le vocabulaire la sert en réalité une
politique bien déterminée et qui n'est
point l'indépendance par conséquent qui
à mes yeux n'est pas le bien de la
france au contraire pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui alors que le marché européen
sourd alors qu'il faut un si grand
échange des affaires internationales
enseigne souhaite enseigner à la
jeunesse les valeurs nationales c'est
parce que outre ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la liberté et que je ne
reviens pas sur lequel je ne reviens pas
il y a le grand problème de
l'indépendance de la france pour les
années qui viennent
l'essentiel pour notre pays pour ces
travailleurs et pour ses citoyens
c'est que la france est une politique et
que cette politique soit conforme d'une
part à ses intérêts et d'autre part à
incertaine
idéal si l'on veut que la france joue un
rôle soit capable de se défendre
influent sur l'avenir de l'europe est la
responsabilité de son destin il importe
que l'on sache que l'idée patriotique
est à la barre
de toute politique sérieuse c'est cela
me semble t'il le débat et non pas telle
discussion sur telle ou telle forme
l'activité économique
au fond ce que monsieur michel debré
vient de dire je crois est une
conclusion en ce qui le concerne cette
première partie du débat
alors je voudrais je me serais prétend
monsieur jacques duclos
non mais lui aussi puisque le temps des
grecs monsieur jacques duclos lui aussi
répondre oui en ce qui le concerne de la
même façon avant que nous passions à la
seconde partie du débat monsieur devait
les prétendantes le patriotisme serait
pour nous un moyen pour dissimuler une
la légende
à la vérité le patriotisme est un moyen
pour les hommes du grand capital que
vous êtes pour dc la capitale aurait
dissimulé pour dissimuler une allégeance
à des puissances important dit regarde
écoute écoute et regarde et déjà la
différence qu'il ya dans votre politique
et si l'essai bras pas mais la
différence entre votre politique par
rapport à il ya quelques temps
et bien maintenant on va à obama à
washington bientôt et on dit qu'il n'y a
aucun désaccord
aucun désaccord sur le vietnam notamment
entre la france et les états unis
ce n'était pas la tonalité du discours
de campagne que vous n'avez pas oublié
exemple non non non non mais enfin
écoutez le paraît pas tout en un
ou alors à leur laisse plus par écoute
nous laver à la vérité vous effraie
colère et c'est clair je ne dit plus un
mot vous essayer de présenter la pâte et
de présenter comme un ange pourcentage à
la vérité pour représenter des intérêts
sordides les intérêts des monopoles
capitalistes
ce monsieur eric est venu défendre ses
intérêts la pénétration du capital
étranger en france
et bien ce monsieur est reine il a joué
un rôle bon je comprends très bien mais
à la vérité
vous êtes le gouvernement des monopoles
capitalistes vous êtes le gouvernement
de la vie chère vous êtes le
gouvernement quoique kennedy quoique les
d'hier soir monsieur le premier ministre
vous êtes le gouvernement de la biche
est parce que c'est vous qui hausser les
tarifs publics
ces boues qui portait la responsabilité
de cela et dans votre politique est bien
les intérêts des travailleurs ne peut
jamais en ligne de compte
ils entrent en ligne de compte dans la
mesure où vous avez vous êtes obligés de
faire quelque chose pour eux non à la
vérité votre patriotisme s'arrête là où
commencent les intérêts voilà bien sûr
des intérêts capitalistes ne pas
accepter cette formule est une formule
que je comprends parfaitement du point
de vue de la propagande mais qui est
l'expression tous tellement caricaturale
de la vie politique qu'elle en est un
mensonge
nous sommes dans un système démocratique
avec une liberté qui est une liberté
politique et une liberté économique
il y à un développement de l'entreprise
privée petite moyenne ou grande est la
doctrine est je le répète que leur
pouvoir politique soit indépendant de
toutes ses activités économiques et sur
l'île de les orienter et je puis vous
dire que le gouvernement est totalement
indépendant et je puis l'affirmer avec
beaucoup plus de conviction que vous
même la firme y est tout à l'heure mais
ce qui est important de dire et ce qui
est important de savoir c'est que le
sens du bien national je peux vous
l'affirmer et vous le savez bien le sens
du bien national qui est l'aspiration de
tous les français c'est bien ce qui nous
fait agir
et quand nous parlons de patriotisme
vous nous parler de votre point de vue
moi je parle du mien mais mettez vous un
instant non pas militant de tel ou tel
parti
mais le français qui vit et qui regarde
que pense-t-il de ce patriotisme
vous ne lui avez pas répondu moi j'ai
essayé de lui répondre
le patriotisme de ce français c'est le
sentiment que les hommes politiques et
tous les dirigeants ont une tâche
première ils ont la responsabilité du
sort des français responsabilité
économique responsabilité sociale c'est
cela l'application du patriotisme à la
viabilité
monsieur
voyez monsieur jacques bigot comme on
dit l'assemblée nationale que de might
look plus exactement la première partie
de ce débat puisque maintenant c'est
michel bassi qui va permettre aux
téléspectateurs qui sont ici de poser à
leur tour un certain nombre de questions
oui la parole maintenant s'ils voulaient
est aux français il y à issy 30
personnes réparties en trois tables de
10 à ma droite qui lie à la table de
ceux qui disent on ont connu la
troisième république
il ya devant moi la table de ceux dont
la mémoire politique est née avec la
quatrième république
et puis il y à la table de ceux qui ne
peuvent avoir connu que la vème
république
c'est donc un critère d'âge qui a été
retenue par la sofres qui a fait cette
sélection pour retenir les personnes qui
sont si ici ce soir mais je précise que
la sofres a également chercher à
pondérer
selon les catégories
socioprofessionnelles et également selon
les opinions politiques les champions
entre guillemets de qui se trouvent ici
ce soir et qui bien entendu ne peut pas
prétendre être une représentation exacte
de la population française je me tourne
maintenant donc vers les trois
animateurs de table et je crois andré
campanaire la première question je crois
michel bassi que la première question
sera en fait posé par les trois tables
et qu'elle porte sur l'europe
la première question donc est posée ici
à cette table mais aux trois en même
temps c'est monsieur nord d'étudiants
qui l'attend
confondre profonde intérêts permanents
de la france avec un grand idéal humain
voilà qui serait beau en donnant ainsi
aux problèmes une dimension planétaire
le général de gaulle lui donne tout son
sens dans votre film monsieur le
ministre
une personne déclare avoir coup du
patriotisme il s'agit de défendre la
dignité d'ouvriers ses dimensions sont
pas étrangères l'une à l'autre
ne voyez vous pas là une mise en cause
aujourd'hui du mode horde prolétaires de
tous pays unissez vous il ya une erreur
sur la question cette fois les sur
l'avenir excusez nous nous allons
prendre
monsieur louer
je crois oui la deuxième question sur
mon rôle dans le cadre de l'europe la
grande la grande bretagne en y accédant
ne risque-t-elle pas de créer un trouble
économique à nos partenaires et à nous
par la peur de ces produits sur le
marché commun sur genève heures
étudiants une question plus
particulièrement pour monsieur debré
comment peut-on se faire une idée de la
patrie dans une europe unie pleinement
réalisées elles sont toutes sortes de
questions sur l'europe espère ici aussi
nous avons une autre formulation si vous
voulez monsieur et si un jour l'idée de
patrie française
remplacé par l'idée de patrie l'europe
et si oui comment et quand
j'avais d'autres choses du même ordre à
porcieu alors ma question était la
suivante elle rejoint parfaitement
d'ailleurs celle de monsieur ne pensez
vous pas que la notion de patrie tendent
à s'élargir jusqu'à une prise de
conscience de patrie européenne ces
questions sont fortes importante
de quoi s'agit-il quand on parle
d'europe
quand on parle d'europe d'abord il faut
bien voir que la définition même de ce
mot est de plus en plus imprécis il y a
quelques années aujourd'hui encore on
parle de l'europe des six maintenant
avec l'entrée de la grande bretagne
envisage l'europe des 10 puis on peut
envisager une europe encore plus grande
et dans la mesure où on s'oriente vers
une conférence de sécurité européenne on
peut imaginer même une europe encore
plus large
il y à déjà dans cette imprécision le
signe que la notion d'unité et la notion
d' union sont accolés à une sphère
géographique qui est insuffisamment
précises
quand nous parlons d'europe ce que nous
souhaitons en use analysant bien c'est
que nous souhaitons d'abord du point de
vue économique et qu'il y ait une très
grande liberté de circulation car nous
pensons qu'un très vaste marché est en
effet utile au développement des
entreprises et par conséquent au niveau
de vie des travailleurs et que le cas
échéant nous pouvons accepter des
troubles supplémentaires par un
élargissement 6 et élargissement
économiquement représente une capacité
supplémentaire
à nous de nous en servir c'est aussi une
sorte de sentiment d'ordre social dans
la mesure où des pays de civilisation
analogue mettent leurs efforts en commun
pour améliorer le niveau de vie général
et puis il ya aussi éventuellement le
sentiment politique un effort de
coopération entre les vieilles nations
européennes diminuera
ce qui dans le passé fut des sujets de
temps
et par conséquent des sujets de conflit
mais la grave erreur qui a été commise
et qui est encore commises c'est de
penser que pour résoudre ses problèmes
économiques sociaux et politiques
la constitution d'un état soit une
condition nécessaire ou indispensable
parce qu'alors on tue à peu près toute
la construction car attire 1 et à
construire une nation n'est point
artificiel il faut justement ce
sentiment de la solidarité qu'ils aient
le sentiment national alors comme l'a
dit une fois le général de gaulle que de
génération en génération
après des échanges de jeunes répété
pendant des années et des années
le patriotisme des vieilles nations sans
devant lui un nouveau patriotisme
s'élever peut-être mais dites vous bien
que nous n'en sommes pas là et que
lorsque nous voyons nos partenaires
qu'il s'agisse de l'italie de
l'allemagne de l'angleterre ou de nos
voisins du benelux nous sentons bien que
dans toutes les discussions
c'est d'abord la défense de leurs
intérêts la défense de leur influence
est qu en effet nous sommes à un moment
où toutes ces idées économiques sociales
et politiques n'ont de chance d'avancer
que dans la mesure où les pâtes riz ou
les états s'entendent en d'autres termes
oui pour une organisation européenne
économique pour un développement
européen d'ordre social
oui pour un effort d'entente allant au
delà de ce qu'on appelait le rideau de
fer
mais pensez bien et que l'on pense bien
que cela se fera sur la réalité
politique qui est celle des sentiments
nationaux travaillons pour un lointain
avenir
mais en attendant dans le présent ne
deale n'ont pas notre pays nous y
perdrions non seulement la défense de
nos intérêts mais ce qui fait notre
influence profonde dans ces conditions
n'en doutez pas il faut aller vers un
effort d'organisation du continent
européen
mais il faut le faire en partant de ce
qui est solide et réelle les états les
nations les patries et pour ce qui nous
concerne
avant toute chose et pour bien des
raisons pour le souci de notre
indépendance politique
l'état la nation et la patrie française
oui il ya des forces économiques et
politiques qui travaillent tant vue de
la réalisation d'une europe
supranationale dont je voudrais dire où
les dangers qu'elle comporte ray pour
notre pays il faut voir ce que
représente cette europe
aujourd'hui les monopoles capitalistes
les plus importants les plus forts sont
les monopoles capitalistes allemands
si l'on tient compte de l'entrée dans
lequel de l'angleterre ben il est
évident que la france serait dans une
large mesure minorisées dans une europe
supranationale
puis il faut dire que l'europe des six
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui ou 17
ou des huit des dix jeunes en arrière
demain et bien cette europe-là
représente un bloc militaire est en
passe de cette europe il ya un autre
bloc militaire
nous considérons nous que ce qu'il faut
ce à quoi il faut tendre
c'est à la disparition des blocs
militaires existants et cela ne peut se
faire et cela ne peut se faire que par
l'établissement la substitution d'un
traité européen de sécurité collective à
aux blocks europe au bloc militaire
c'est pourquoi nous sommes partisans
nous d'un traité de sécurité européenne
collective et leurs proches ont
justement au gouvernement français de
n'être pas assez actif dans ce domaine
il s'est prononcé pour ça je le sais
mais il n'est pas très actif dans ce
domaine parce qu'il ya plusieurs façon
d'enterrer une question celle de dire
connaître résolument contre hausse est
de laisser les choses en longueur
nous avons l'impression qu'on laisse
traîner les choses en longueur alors ce
que c'est un problème de la pelure
d'importation nous quittons s'ils
voulaient bien le domaine européen une
autre question la compagnie
une question qui s'adresse d'une
génération au fond à une autre c'est à
dire d'une génération de gens jeunes
deux hommes politiques ayant une
certaine expérience elle concerne
l'avenir dit expérience et l'aura
vieillesse merci oui certainement
le nord étudiant entre la société de
consommation qui abrutit et les 100
sites entre la société de consommation
qui abrutit et la société de propagande
qui anéantit l'homme il n'y a t'il pas
place selon vous afin d'avoir une patrie
qu'ils soient plus à une troisième voie
une deuxième formulation qui s'adresse
cette fois ci à monsieur debré je
demande à monsieur debré si l'évolution
de la politique gouvernementale depuis
le départ du général de gaulle qui était
marqué par alliance avec les centristes
par l'ouverture par une europe
technocrates ne risque pas de conduire à
l'abandon précise la notion de patrie et
finalement laisser le monopole ou parti
communiste une troisième formulation
mademoiselle carole valero il s'adresse
aux deux hommes politiques être patriote
est pas acheter une machine à laver un
crédit entre patriotes s ne pas acheter
une machine à laver à crédit les villes
parce qu'une allusion à certains aspects
du gouvernement reste
je voudrais que je voudrais que les
jeunes fassent un peu attention quand on
parle de société de consommation qui
abrutit essais et tous ses défauts vous
avez une vision qui est évidemment très
bien répandu actuellement de la société
de consommation qui apporterait avec
elle tous les vices songez que il y a
encore 50 ou 80 ans ce qu'était la
mortalité infantile
ce qu'était même les difficultés de la
vie
pour un très grand nombre de ménages à
l'heure actuelle en 50 ans où en
soixante ans les progrès de la technique
de la technique scientifique de la
technique médicale de la technique tout
court les progrès économiques honte
amener un changement très grand vous ne
voyez plus de mère pleurant sur leur le
leurs enfants morts dans le berceau
comme on le voyait d'une manière
constante il ya encore 100 ans avec la
médecine
vous ne voyez plus de ces cortèges de
mendiants comme on l'envoyait il ya cent
ans
donc je demande aux jeunes au moment où
il condamne les défauts de la société de
consommation de voir les considérables
progrès accomplis depuis 100 ans et
notamment dans un pays comme comme la
france
cela est capital pour juger des choses
sainement je ne dis pas qu'il n'y a pas
d'abus et il y en a et justement quand
on essaie de parler et faire comprendre
l'intérêt général de faire comprendre ce
que représente la solidarité de tous les
français pour que la prospérité
économique profite à tous pour que cet
immense sécurité sociale ces excellentes
allocations familiales expression de la
vie patriotique de tous les jours
puisque c'est l'expression de la
solidarité se développe c'est bien
quelque chose qui corrige tous les
défauts que l'on dit volontiers être
celui de la société de consommation le
tout et vous avez raison c'est de bien
savoir qu'il y a un intérêt général qui
exige de se servir de la technique et
non pas le faire que la technique soit
mènerait c'est le cas échéant aïe
loin dans la voix demande brièvement
maintenant car nous avons aujourd'hui
dit je veux dire que la société de
conservation me paraît improprement
nommé parce que on peut il ya des gens
qui consomment bien c'est entendu il ya
des gens qui ne consomment pas assez et
cette société dont un spectacle assez
qui regrette par exemple il y a deux
on a détruit des centaines de milliers
de pommes de pêche de poires toutes
sortes de fruits alors ce que n'aurait
plus donné sa de braves gens qui
n'avaient pas la possibilité d'acheter
ces produits là par conséquent procès de
société de consommation et bien c'est
une société qui ne permet pas à tout le
monde de consommer selon ses besoins
quelqu'un dit n'est pas d'accord avec ce
sujet qu un téléphone tout de suite
c'est une autre histoire
alors je peux encore ajouter une chose
c'est que voyez-vous notre société
tellement mal faite avec le système
capitaliste que nous exportons il vaut
mieux prendre son temps il vaut mieux
produire trop ri mais pas d'atouts mais
pas des produits représentés par les
images c'est pas des pluies pas détruit
et non pas des prix il faut pas produire
pour détruire
il faut produire pour consommer et non
pas pour détruire et voyez comment c'est
tellement bien fait on exporte on paye
chaque aube accueillant 70 240 milliards
d'anciens francs pour exporter des
céréales excédentaire et nous allons
payer 140 milliards ou 150 milliards
d'anciens francs pour importer de la
viande de porc qu'on pourrait avoir à
partir de ces céréales et excellente
tout ça c'est mal fait c'est très mal
faits précis steve votre gommage
je vous signale je te signale que parmi
les acheteurs de ces céréales
ils y ont notamment les pays communistes
mais au moins 18 à celle ci a progressé
très mal heureusement qu'il ya des pays
libéraux il faut faire du blé à venir
les pays socialistes
les connaît la collectivisation n'arrive
pas aux pirates et la question c'est la
volaille d'affaires je vous explique
pourquoi on en vol mais je vous rassure
ce n'est pas seulement les dames comme
souvent des jeunes à ce qu'on nous fait
pas peur à manger du club nous savons
produire et donc vous savez des temps
nous avons c'est une autre question à
laquelle il serait en force d'importante
qui a été dit tout à l'heure et brimeux
touche directement au jeu pourrait
répondre simplement non la question
posée
il m'a posé la question suivante est-ce
que depuis quelques mois certaines
révolutions économiques ne conduirait
pas à une technocratie supra nationales
ou internationales qui disent souderait
cette notion fondamentale d'intérêt
national je réponds non je crois ma
fenêtre expliqué tout à l'heure le
développement économique est liée à des
échanges internationaux et ces échanges
internationaux ont leurs lois leurs
avantages et les inconvénients mais
l'essentiel est d'avoir une claire
conscience de ce que représente
l'intérêt de la france l'intérêt de la
france dans l'europe
c'est cela la leçon du général de gaulle
l'intérêt de la france en elle-même dans
l'europe et dans le monde
et sur ce point croyez bien que quels
que soient les changements d'hommes la
ligne générale est suivie c'est bien ça
qui fait la permanence d'un patriotisme
qui n'est pas le patriotisme d'une
fraction qui n'est pas le patriotisme de
quelques-uns mais qui est le souci de
cet intérêt général profondes des
français qui doit animer et qui nous
anime encore encore et encore et bien
non ça il faut le dire il faut le faire
et prétendent que la machine à laver est
un obstacle au redressement économique
du pays alors là toutes les leçons des
questions des avocats ça vole bas
voulez-vous que nous passions une autre
question qui classe s'il vous plaît la
question de l'attaqué devant moi
question que nous pouvons être évier il
vous plait il faudra jouer pas coulé
résumé oui elle concerne l'attitude de
nouriel tour face aux obligations
militaires surveillent du patriote
madame baumann pensez vous qu un
objecteur de conscience est un bon ou un
mauvais patriote monsieur magret pensez
vous qu'un jeune soldat du contingent
avait la conviction de défendre la
patrie en algérie le sionisme and the
bow temps être patriote sans être
militariste voit la france a fait un
ensemble viennent je dirais que pour les
objecteurs de conscience
ils ont une chance inouïe c'est que les
autres soient patriotes et que vivent
dans un pays où l'ensemble des citoyens
acceptent de défendre les libertés eux
peuvent en user et le cas échéant en
abuser je ne les juge pas je dis
simplement ils ont une immense chance
d'être dans un pays où le patriotisme de
la majorité leur permet d'agir à leur
guise
pour ce qui concerne l'algérie
la question est douloureuse et vous le
savez bien
nous avons pendant des générations
estimé que l'effort fait par la france
créée en algérie un sentiment
d'appartenance à la communauté française
et qu'il fallait défendre cette algérie
n'a il s'est trouvé que le vent de
l'histoire à créer de telles 10
sentiment en algérie que la notion d'une
nouvelle patrie est née chez les
musulmans et il y a eu de ce fait la
rupture que vous savez mais au départ et
pour tous les français tous les français
quel qu'il soit il y avait bien le
sentiment que nous pouvions estimé avoir
là-bas une partie de la communauté
française
l'évolution des esprits le libre droit
des peuples à déterminer de même à
changer le cours du destin
quant à être patriote sans être
militariste je vous dirai ceci on peut
effectivement être patriote sans être
militariste mais quand on est patriote
on vote pour les crédits de la défense
nationale
et vous les utilisez bien pour monsieur
dassault pour l'enrichir
oui je voulais dire ceci c'est que
monsieur debré parle de l'algérie est un
peu gêné parce qu'au fond vous avez
prolongé la garde pendant trois ans
inutilement inutilement les paie plus de
monde pour rien parce qu'au fond il
aurait fallu commencer par là vous avez
fini et puis vous vous rendez compte
vous avez nier vous avez contesté aux
algériens pendant longtemps le droit
d'avoir une patrie je vous rappelle
monsieur du coup ce que vous avez signé
un projet de loi portant statut de
l'algérie est dans la première phase
était l'algérie fait partie intégrante
de la franchise est signée jacques
duclos oui mais nous sommes au rappel
d'un cloaque
c'était en 1946 et d'autre part monsieur
jacques duclos je vous rappelle que vous
avez voté les pleins pouvoirs à un
gouvernement qui a envoyé le contingent
en algérie
sur ce point monsieur duclos vous avez
ne vous cachez pas vous avez vous lu
comme tout le monde et vous avez espérer
comme tout le monde que l'algérie
continuerait à faire partie de la
communauté française
vous l'avez dit et vous avez mis vos
votes en harmonie avec votre pensée par
conséquent je ne voudrais pas qu'on joue
seulement nous justement vous revenir
seulement nous nous n'avons pas été
comme vous nous avons combattu votre
politique vous avez été au gouvernement
votre politique de poursuite de la
guerre le général de gaulle avait
continué pendant trois jeux me permets
de vous dire qu'en général de gaulle a
fait la paix vous à ce que les
gouvernements que vous aviez soutenu ne
faisait pas oui il a fait la paix et
vous ayant un nommé chalandon qui
raconte que vous vous essayez mais
derrière tout ça a l'airé de golf à part
le dernier bon enfin c'est que je ne
vais vous dire et vous ne croirez sur ce
point et que le général de gaulle était
peu influençable
oui non je vous ai feuillet 12 ans
derrière par derrière
derrière nom alors je veux dire vous
n'avez pas vous avait contesté aux
algériens le droit d'avoir une patrie
mais vous contestez aussi ce droit en
quelque sorte aux réunionnais vous est
donné l'occasion d'aller à la brute et
du clos entre nous cela
yoro bayonne thon rouge attend le
patriote monsieur dégâts monsieur du
coup allez vous y présenter non je vous
y attends mais messi
avec qui à la barre du club tout le
monde ici même à examiner le système de
fraude à saint denis seine municipalité
communiste et à saint denis de la
réunion au csad n'y fait rien les
communistes vitrine 3 et que beaucoup
vous assure sur ce point je voudrais
passer votre question je suis en piste à
nous annoncer ça mais ça donne aussi
christian bernadac s'ils voulaient vivre
la dernière derrière une question de
monsieur roger clairet qui s'adresse à
monsieur jacques du coup ça n'a rien
d'un si dieu c'est simplement pour mon
information non je lis ainsi tout au
long de votre film vous avez voulu
démontrer l'intégrité du patriotisme des
communistes pouvez vous nous dire
pourquoi vous avez recommandé
l'abstention lors de la dernière
consultation électorale mettant ainsi
beaucoup de nos compatriotes dans
l'impossibilité de faire leurs devoirs
et bien là je vais vous répondre très
simplement
vous savez dans quelles conditions on
savait dans quelles conditions j'ai été
candidat j'ai mené une campagne très
clair et j'ai combattu à la fois le
candidat de l'idée est monsieur pompidou
et le candidat centriste monsieur power
alors je n'ai pas dis moi il pourra
choisir entre la peste et le choléra je
l'aimé pas ces deux termes je n'aime pas
ce terme médicaux purpose palmer j'ai
parlé de bonnet blanc et blanc bonnet ça
me paraissait à la fois plus anodins et
plus conforme à la réalité alors au fond
nous avons pensé lorsque nous sommes
premiers en présence d'une situation il
fallait choisir entre monsieur poher et
monsieur pompidou nous ne voulions
choisir un porno ni pour l'autre alors
comment faire
ben le seul moyen c'est est de
préconiser une abstention active n'avons
pas préconisé la fuite devant le scrutin
nous avons expliqué les raisons pour
lesquelles nous demander aux électeurs
de ne pas voter
et ma foi il faut croire que notre
sentiment note
les occupations répondait à la volonté
d'un grand nombre de français puisque
nous avons s'était largement suivi c'est
dans ces conditions là que nous avons
pris notre décision et que nous avons
non pas à détourner les français les
citoyens de leur devoir mais nous avons
17 noeuds ligne a pas d'autre moyen pour
vous maintenant que de voter dans ces
conditions de vous abstenir haut font
bien souvent au parlement il ya prés
façon de voter à votre tour on vote
contre ou ne participent pas au vote
mais là on ne pouvait pas recommandé de
voter blanc parce que c'était nous avons
préconisé l'abstention ayant un certain
nombre de citoyens qui ont appliqué
notre mot d'ordre on se rendant aux
urnes parce que il y avait aussi cette
idée c'est que dans un petit village on
se faire remarquer et le fait de ne pas
voter c'est être une indication
par conséquent il ya des gens qui sont
rendus aux urnes et ma foi ne peut pas
leur en vouloir
en votant blanc voilà nous avons fait
monsieur debré un dernier mot si vous
voulez bien pour conclure commencer les
travaux coupures
quelle est la question que l'on peut se
poser c'est la suivante me semble t'il
peut-on doit-on être patriote en 1970 la
réponse elle est affirmatif elle est
affirmative
d'abord parce que l'on ne peut pas l'on
ne doit pas renier son passé mais laisse
aussi affirmative
parce que l'essentiel c'est de se sentir
un citoyen est un citoyen c'est un homme
qui a une patrie l'essentiel c'est
d'être un peuple libre ayant ses droits
et ses responsabilités dans la société
internationale et pour que ce peuple
exerce ses droits il faut qu'il soit une
patrie en d'autres termes dans notre vie
politique qui est toute action qui est
toute agitation et qui est lié aux
circonstances
il ya cependant une loi morale et cette
loi morale c'est le fondement sur lequel
se fonde la liberté des hommes et la
solidarité des peuples
c'est pourquoi nous autres français
conscients de notre liberté d'homme
conscients de notre responsabilité
nationale nous pouvons comme nos
ancêtres et nous pouvons comme nos
enfants le front crier vive la patrie
moi je pense que dans ce 20ème siècle
oui on ne peut pas quand on est français
comme temps appartient pays quelconque
on ne peut pas ne pas tenir compte de
l'intérêt de son propre pays et de
l'avenir de son propre pays moi je suis
patriote
j'aime la france et je veux pour la
france un régime nouveau
c'est pourquoi j'aspire à voir la france
socialiste demain c'est ma conviction
profonde parce que je pense que c'est le
seul moyen de préparer un avenir autre
que celui qu'on lui prépare aujourd'hui
et quand tout à l'heure je parlais dans
mon film des deux chansons françaises
vous ne pouvez pas imaginer ce que ça
fait quand on est dans un pays étranger
qu'on entend ces deux chansons
monsieur devrez ne connaît pas la
deuxième évidemment c'est entendu enfin
je sais je suis sur la première ces deux
chansons qui sont venus de chez nous ils
sont venus de chez nous et qui ont fait
le tour du monde ben ça représente
quelque chose mais l'exclusivisme en
matière de patriotisme ne va pas non
plus parce que nous sommes dans un monde
où les nations s'interpénètrent et c'est
pourquoi nous disons qu'il n'ya pas
contradiction entre le patriotisme qui
n'a rien de commun avec le chauvinisme
parce que le nationalisme comme disait
le docteur c'est le patriotisme qui
manque de noblesse
n'est ce pas et bien non le patriotisme
n'a rien de commun avec le chauvinisme
pas plus que l'internationalisme tel que
nous le concevons n'a rien de commun
avec l'internationalisme je veux finir
et je veux terminer et je veux terminer
par un mot de jean jaurès un mot de jean
jaurès qui a dit et je fais mien ce mot
là un peu d'internationalisme éloigne de
la patrie beaucoup d'internationalisme y
ramène un peu c'est l'alignement sur un
autre nationalisme 7 ans et pourquoi
nous sommes beaucoup d'intérêt et ce
n'est pas l'alignement sur les monopoles
capitalistes comme dans bien cette fois
je crois que le débat vraiment clos dans
le feu de la discussion nous avons
dépassé le temps qui nous étaient
accordées aux sabots bien seul je le
pense armes égales va s'achever
auparavant je voudrais m'adresser aux
téléspectateurs leur demander de nous
écrit pour nous dire si cette nouvelle
formule de face à face leur a plu ou
s'ils ont des suggestions à faire pour
améliorer ou transformer cette émission
écrive une longue si vous voulez bien à
armes égales que 15 heures cognacq jay
paris viième arrondissement
voilà merci monsieur duclos merci
monsieur debré merci
[Musique]